viele wähler sind vielleicht immer noch
sauer weil söder so lange am rechten
rand gefischt hat wissen sie das hat
viele menschen in bayern zu den grünen
getrieben und die verstrahlten denen
sowas gefällt die wählen wohl lieber das
original die afd zuletzt besonders
erfolgreich im wahlkreis deggendorf hfd
straßenwahlkampf
sie sind schon deutsche staatsbürger aha
okay dann dürfen sie abwählen in
deggendorf
damit gebe ich ihnen lernte bald wird
damit die afg kennt er noch nicht er
möchte die unterlagen zu hause in ruhe
lesen ja mach das ließ die bitte in ruhe
auch das kleingedruckte ganz wichtig und
für alle die noch damit liebäugeln aus
protest am sonntag afd zu wählen weil
das ja im prinzip eine ganz normale
partei ist der af dem mann andreas
winhart kandidiert für den bayerischen
landtag und sagte bei einer öffentlichen
veranstaltung letzte woche dass hier
es gibt unglaublich viele hiv fälle die
g10 staaten ist es gibt auch grenzen
meine darüber und ich möchte wissen wenn
mich in den nachbarschaften die geküsst
habe oder anruf dann muss ich wissen ist
der kann podest
wir freuen uns für sicherstellen
du bist krank das ist mir ganz sicher
freundchen unglaublich
[Applaus]
unser
natürlich sind dann alle gemäßigten live
dealer im saal wütend aufgesprungen
sie war damals gibt ja gar keine
gemäßigten 8 bei einem fehler alice
weidl saß bei der ansprache übrigens nur
zwei meter daneben und wenn sie das eben
schon widerlich fanden kratzer an die
ihr habt noch einen ganzen sack voll
braune sprüche im köcher wir haben 14
punkte die chancen die ard im
bayerischen wald hinein zu schicken von
merkel in den ruhestand zu senden und
diese stören mich als rettungsversuchen
mittelmeers gesehen
bingo da war ja wirklich alles dabei
flüchtlinge versenken und so roß flotte
wegen george soros der name der immer
fällt als codewort für die jüdische
weltverschwörung denn das nur mal als
kleines betthupferl für sogenannte
protestwählern wer rechtsextreme wählt
wählt rechtsextrem punkt so ganz harten
schnitt meine damen und herren
reden wir jetzt mal über die grünen ja
nicht nur in bayern
auch bundesweit sieht in den umfragen
gerade ganz gut aus für die manche sehen
die grünen sogar schon auf dem weg zur
neuen volkspartei ja warum nicht warum
wir nicht ja
einfach ja also quasi aus der nische in
die mitte das passiert gerade dadurch
wird man zwar inhaltlich ein bisschen
beliebiger aber irgendwas ist immer
die grünen stehen voll im saft und clown
stimmen von fast allen anderen parteien
und sie haben uns vorgewarnt sehr laut
sogar wenn es in vier jahren wollen gibt
dass wir dann so stark sind dass keiner
mehr an uns vorbeikommt und das ist egal
ist was die anderen treiben dass wir
einfach in die regierung kommen und
dafür sorgen dass es getan wird was so
wenig ist danke
[Applaus]
junge junge vor der rede hat damit
ochsenblut gekurbelt nicht nur jahrelang
jahre lang haben die grünen ihren
aufstieg geplant strategisch geplant
unter dem internen decknamen operation
hinkelstein ja und wenn sich das
angucken die sind tatsächlich im jahr
2018 ganz weg von benji day und fünf
mark pro liter benzin
heute heißt es bloß kein mehr
erschrecken und das funktioniert zum
ersten mal überhaupt hat die partei mehr
als 70.000 mitglieder
es ist schon ein erfolg die grünen die
grünen sind heute so etwas wie das
rundum-sorglos-paket da ist für jeden
was dabei
naturschutz klar aber auf eine
erwachsene art in hessen zb hat der
grüne energie minister widerspruch gegen
fahrverbote eingelegt als früher auch
nicht gegeben gut grün ist halt mehr
sonnen gefühl atme einatmen heiße luft
rein
heiße luft
[Musik]
nicht nur eine partei sondern auch eine
farm macht den herabschauen den wähler
mit schlacke dich von lästigen inhalten
der demokratische die tanks für den
gestressten welt wo ihn nicht dein leben
[Applaus]
fühlt man sich direkt besser
neben dem baum bündnis 90/die wellness
partei ja und offensichtlich aktuell
auch eine art projektionsfläche für alle
menschen die von anderen parteien
irgendwie enttäuscht sind in bayern
stehen die grünen laut politbarometer
von gestern bei 19 prozent mit ihrem
spitzenduo schulze und hartmann
kennen sie eine sehr fesch oder sehr
fesch wie aus dem manufactum katalog
ausgeschnitten der wahnsinn hier
katharina schulze und ihr schönstes
wahlkampf erlebnis und ich weiß noch als
ich das allererste mal da klingeln
sollte dachte ich mir ernsthaft ich
bringe doch nicht an irgend so eine
haustür oder lag es einfach mal
ausprobiert und dann sagst du mir so wie
großartig ist das denn wie kraus
ich drückte auf den knopf gegenden oder
die tür auf und so verpiss dich du gut
werfen pflege
großartig war das denn ja junge lief es
so gut gelaufen
[Applaus]
und wer weiß das ja eine option die
keiner ausschließt vielleicht regieren
die in bayern bald mit der csu ja warum
nicht wird bestimmt super nur noch
zweimal schlafen so geil wird
schwarz-grün in bayern nicht gestiegen
hartmann herr söder steht wenn sie
interesse haben hat man ja so hat man
ich finde ich jetzt interessieren hat
man sich persönlich meinte der finne war
ja leider nicht besitzen
die gebärdendolmetscherin hat übrigens
nach fünf sekunden gekündigt zu recht
aber ist das ein dauerbrenner dieser
grüne hype oder doch nur eine
momentaufnahme
auffällig ist dass die anderen parteien
tatsächlich schon anfangen die grünen zu
imitieren ja hier cdu mann volker
bouffier reitet im hessischen wahlkampf
auf einem freiland huhn wie verzweifelt
muss man sein es ist ja wahnsinn so was
genau ist das geheimnis des grünen
höhenflugs wie geht das solche prozent
zahlen ohne dass ein einziges
atomkraftwerk explodiert ist sprechen
wir darüber mit dr birte schneider
sie leitet für bündnis 90 die grünen ein
forschungslabor vdr schneider was wird
da geforscht bei ihnen na ja inhaltlich
haben wir die grünen ja schon sehr
erfolgreich entkernt in den letzten
jahren
jetzt war die frage wie verpackt man die
attraktiv diese totale leere und
deswegen setzen in bayern jetzt erstmals
keine menschlichen spitzenkandidaten
mehr ein sondern zwei androiden die
modelle
marina und ludwig schön oder hat das
sind roboter ja ja ja mit menschen haben
die grünen einfach schlechte erfahrungen
gemacht
ich sag mal so trittin der hat eine aura
wenn der irgendwo rein kommt dafür
wählten die blumen die beiden hier
dagegen die mag jeder wobei ich zugeben
muss bei katharina da muss ich das
fröhlichkeit module noch so ein bisschen
runterregeln too much
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin also was stimmt die grünen haben
neuerdings immer total attraktive
spitzenkandidaten ach guck mal an hat
das auch schon gemerkt herr welke nach
den sahneschnitten baerbock und habeck
habe ich mit diesen beiden hobbys hier
den vogel abgeschossen attraktiv aber
nicht zu attraktiv ganz wichtig das
empfinden die hässlichen wähler als
bedrohung
sexy aber jugendfrei und darüber lasse
ich nichts dem zufall
hier das modell ludwig beim pressetermin
im wald eigentlich wollen wir gerade
unser interview beginnen
grünes bilderbuch das reh war natürlich
auch ein roboter wenn du heute
volkspartei sein willst musst du
sämtliche ecken und kanten abschleifen
niemanden verschrecken oder
intellektuell überfordern so geht
mainstream kennen sie ja von ihren gags
moment tendenziell sind die grünen schon
noch so eine art linke parteien sich
deshalb haben die ja schon bei der
allerersten jamaika sondierung auf die
vermögenssteuer verzichtet logisch
umverteilungen macht ja auch wenig sinn
wenn deine wähler schweine reich sind
ich meine du sechster nicht an dem kia
samen baum auf dem du sitzt sein
ja ja ich weiß nicht mehr katharina und
ludwig bestimmt nett aber ich vermisse
doch die zotteligen grün meiner jugend
herr welke damit nahm er so lange genug
versucht mein erster prototyp damals
gottes der in die hose gegangen
der toni in windows 98 der lief noch auf
diesel euro 4
da wollte gar nicht mehr nach berlin
gottseidank hörte schneider war darunter
[Applaus]
[Musik]